that like the till tyron woodley fight
well tails a chance to standing up right
that's it and you know if I was tire and
I take them to the ground I mean the
tire is a far better wrestler far much
much more experience but like there's
some fights be like man like here's one
this weekend Brian Ortega max Holloway
yeah well [ __ ] no son that's gonna go
like I've bounced that one around my
head at people people have come up to me
on the street like hey man who's gonna
win this fight this weekend like
specially Hawaiians
yeah Hawaiians are super excited for max
Holloway to win again I mean he's the
new BJ Penn right and it may be a
different level max hallways a
[ __ ]
that's that's one of those fights yeah
it's very hard to pick I was that even
that like it's pretty easy not to be I
mean what's who the Vegas odds are I by
the way I love the fact that you can
actually gamble on fights now online
like it's Li it's legal basically right
you kind of do it right if you if I
would you mind yourself
depending on the state you're too much
I'm not sure I wouldn't want to think
about it unless I knew unless the guy
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] and he's like I'm
gonna go smash this dude just no very
close they're both - - 105 - 125 which
would be all the way as the favorite
flight favorite that make sense yeah
that makes sense that should be how it
is slight favorite cuz he's the champion
and you know what's interesting when
Holloway said he goes he goes it's kind
of weird when he goes it's kind of weird
when the the the new thing is older than
the current thing because it's like I'm
younger man I'm the [ __ ] champ
I beat although I beat all these dudes
I'm younger and yet this guy's the new
thing coming up to challenge me it's
like [ __ ] I'm the younger
fighter it's kind of funny yeah yeah I
mean we haven't seen we haven't seen
something like like Ortega a little bit
you know in the featherweight division
guy submitting like only submissions off
to like the one with Cup yeah you know
yeah I think that was beautiful like he
readjusted on that guillotine - that's
that's probably the hardest submission
to readjust mm-hmm you know one hand
hanging on readjusting and then still
sinking it in against cups one it's not
like it's not like Brandon bishop or
whoever
it's Cubs one Sonata here that's like
that's crazy man
well he's a direct lineage right he's
real Gracie jiu-jitsu
he is Henner and here on you know he's
come he comes from Horry on that school
I mean this is where Brian Ortega comes
from he's direct from those mats yeah
and his technique is like razor blade
it's so sharp it's so sharp and precise
and so honed and just through drills and
a constant emphasis on proper leverage
and position I mean they're sticklers to
that old style of jiu-jitsu like and
some people there's an unfortunate word
that people like to use that sometimes
pisses people off like Vinny Magalhaes
use this to describe Minotauro and he
didn't mean in a negative way but he
meant the basics he's like his jujitsu
is very basic he and people go [ __ ]
much just use basic here but the basic
is like the best the fundamentals but
these there's guys that have those
basics like Roger Gracie his jujitsu is
he's mostly the basics he's not doing
any crazy dela Hiva [ __ ] or anything
that you've never seen before like that
oh yeah he's not doing anything he never
saw it before
it's strict you know guard pass smashing
on top triangle mount arm triangle
armbar everything he does is classic Jiu
Jitsu but it's just so perfect
everything that leverage and the weight
and the emphasis on you know certain
positions over others it's all like
basic classic Jiu Jitsu and that's Brian
Ortega yeah his Jiu Jitsu is just so
rock solid fundamentals you know he's
all about fundamentals though even his
box he's not I don't believe he's as
good a boxer as max but he's
fundamentally sound strong and direct
with his box I mean he knocked out
Frankie he knocked out Frankie he
submitted Meccano who I think is one of
the Dark Horse's yeah that division yeah
an optimal Connor was a [ __ ] beast
man Mike good Mike Brown has nothing but
praise for him man he's like that kid is
legit he's gonna challenge for that
title I believe that I believe that and
he's super like respectful and
intelligent and like everything about
I like I love his his approach the way
he fights and in that fight Holloway our
excuse me Ortega made him shoot because
he was beating him standing up and he
shot and Ortega like thank you that
guillotine it's just a death grip he's
just got a vise just clamps down on your
[ __ ] life yeah put you to sleep
there's no room there's no room you're
going to sleep or you're going to tap
you need a kid he's not my size he's big
he's a big he's big max is big to their
max is huge max was 185 when they told
him about the the khabib nurmagomedov
fight the the horrible thing about that
fight was that he lost all that weight
really rapidly for no reason and then
they wound up pulling him out of the
fight yeah the Commission was like [ __ ]
this you can't fight and a lot of us at
the time were like why is the Commission
telling the champion whether or not he
can make weight let him try to make
weight get the [ __ ] out of there you
don't know what you're doing but then
you find out after that that like when
he was preparing for the the first fight
with Ortega and he was experiencing
these weird concussion-like symptoms
symptoms but they said he didn't have a
concussion and then people say no this
is weight loss this is rapid weight
cutting his body is responding to the
fact that he just went through this and
now I was trying to do it again and his
body's rejecting it so this is a bunch
of theories there's not they're not
giving us a whole lot of information
about exactly what's wrong with him
medically or what was wrong whether they
know it or not I don't know right but
even Ortega has been saying all week
like what the [ __ ] was wrong with him
why not how come they're not telling us
like what if it happens again like
Ortega's got to be thinking right now
here we are today
it's Wednesday tomorrow's Thursday the
weigh-ins Friday he only got a couple of
days like we don't know whether or not
this is even actually gonna happen right
like right what if he gets down to
Thursday and Friday and he's in the the
middle of the weight cut he starts
blacking out or he starts experiencing
those symptoms again they pull him out
of the card
Boyka knows on standby you know I did
not know that yeah he's on standby for
this fight that ya see and then then it
becomes an interim title it must it has
to it can't beat they're not gonna strip
him but then what happens I mean
a guy like max that I don't know it's
it's one of those situations where it's
like if that happens multiple times like
what do you have to do ken can you
continue to how much longer can you
continue to fight at that weight I don't
think he can continue to fight at that
weight very much longer because I think
he severely compromises himself getting
down to 45 but he's been able to do it
because he's a champion but and I think
if you do have a relook at George
Lockhart in your corner a guy that gets
you to do it scientifically and then
rehydrate yourself scientifically it can
be done and you can pull it off in 24
hours later you can fight at a very high
level but is that the way to go I mean
kidneys start breaking down your body
starts getting beat up I mean your
organs don't want to get dried out like
that yeah your brain doesn't want to get
dried out like that your muscles don't
want to get dried out like that there's
just no way you perform at your best
when you're just at death's door 24
hours ago and now here you're fighting
again